[Music]
you know it's just so awesome debbie
wire is now in nashville we're pumped
about it i'm a big fan so i thought well
i gotta show ben around so i thought
well if we're gonna do it
listen you can't be a legitimate country
singer if you don't have a big ass
cadillac you have to have the gas
cadillac so this is 68 cadillac deville
convertible i've had this car about 15
years it's got a 472 under the hood it
is a it is a mustard this is back when
america is still making cars out of
metal right yeah american metal so it'll
be fun right it'll look like we're
running for mayor awesome perfect yeah
all right cool let's go
[Music]
we're so happy to be out of the blue
areas we're so happy to be out of there
jeremy said you went to florida because
the the community down there was suited
to the jewish community yeah there's not
enough people here they're all liberals
here well it's yes it's liberal and also
you need some options
so my theory of politics is that god
gets everybody this is my theory of
politics everybody that's what they
deserve in the end yeah you're gonna get
it
[Music]
now biden's getting what he deserves
he's wanted his entire life to be in
this position and he wants to be beloved
he wants to leave office and he's
six percent he's a thirty six percent
because he's a terrible
president so is it so it's just and
nobody i'm you've seen those polls but
the majority of people don't believe
biden's even running anything
right people just don't they know he's
not and every time he says they told me
i could take a couple i'm supposed to
call on
who told you to do that that's the
question who is telling you these things
who is it is it susan
who's in the background
yeah i mean the truth is we don't
believe it anymore like i think that
he's making like big calls in terms of
afghanistan i think he's making the call
in terms of buildback better that he's
going to push hard for it but i think
that's about it like i just don't i
think that he wakes up for about five
minutes a day yeah and they feed him the
insurer it's elder abuse exactly and
then they like shake him awake long
enough if that was your grandpa if if
joe biden was your granddaddy well i
mean if you ever put him in that face if
joe biden was my grandfather that would
be my mom
right but i mean you would never put
somebody that you cared about in a
position like that hotels are abused
absolutely he's clearly not with it i
mean it's
i would feel bad making fun of him
except he put himself in this position
he's the president of the united states
so i'm not going to stop making it oh
it's open target yeah exactly like i say
on the show i call him president house
plan because he's just barely alive he
performs basic photos really what we
need to do he's never visited the border
all we have to do is just build a nice
ice cream stand right on the border and
you know he'll go at that point he's
done underneath ice cream that's
exciting stuff check it out
so what is the damn deal with the fake
um
oval office setup
where they're shooting his interviews
from this hollywood set what is that
they were saying that it's why are they
social distancing that's well
it's yeah i mean
i don't know it's not social distance
when saki does a
oppressor right
but honestly like so what is that i
don't know i hope that they start piping
in different backgrounds like an
instagram filter like i just think it'd
be great if he's suddenly give anything
he's just an antarctic all of a sudden
and you're like wow that's right niagara
falls
today i'm joining you from niagara falls
yes well why don't you get in a barrel
and roll over the edge
where we're headed up here is uh music
row have you been down music girl yet uh
i don't think so but you know what that
is music bro talk to me about it back in
the day all the studios
all the publishers all the record labels
on one street
literally so you had a multi-billion
dollar
industry
sitting on one street that's called
music road right and so they've had to
you know as nashville has blown up
they've knocked stuff down this and that
but there's still a bunch of it there
elvis cut down there i'm going to show
you where he cut
it's such a pretty town
yeah it's funny we have a we have a red
governor and a blue mayor yeah
so that gets a little interesting whole
orthodox jews it's like descent's number
one fundraising hub is that right oh
yeah absolutely when he was from a
fundraiser he comes to the orthodox
community we raise a bundle you think
he's gonna run i guess it depends on
what trump does it all depends on trump
if trump runs nobody's running
well because here's the thing even if
you beat trump
he's a wrecking ball
trump he's going to tear you lamb from
left right and he's damaged goods when
he gets done with you that's exactly
right so there's no upside to it even if
you emerge with the nomination he'll
have destroyed you so badly in the
primary if don jr ran against donald
trump he would tear don jr oh yeah
he's completely mercenary he does not
know he's like he's an animal and he's
looking at biden and he's like well you
know i'm still younger than that and
i've got well i'm all hopped up with no
place to go even people that
i mean the bull like he's not invited
right now i hated him or whatever
those people are now watching how this
is all going down and going i don't
think so yeah i mean listen he's not
crazy to think he could win a general
against biden at this point now he well
he would win if
if it's legit
yeah i mean listen i think that he's not
the cleanest one yeah because he has the
highest negatives right because biden
didn't get elected because anybody gives
it
but anybody that's going to run for
president as a republican better be
swinging a hammer like trump would swing
it or they're not going to well that's
it so that's the same so
right so
desantis is a bruiser i mean he's a
bruiser he's just been taken to people
in florida and he and he
he knows how to handle the media he's
super smart he went he was a jag in the
navy he's got a really he's got a really
good really good record like if ron runs
it's gonna be hard it's gonna be hard to
take him and also
like what he did during the pandemic
guy's got stones yeah he goes okay you
want to have this then fine i'm just
going to find you every single time you
do it right
what are you going to do about it
exactly yeah i mean it's he makes other
governors look like they're all a bunch
of panty weights exactly so he's he's
doing a great job
i think that governors are absolutely
the most important position
in our country right now because they
have 100
100 they're the only ones that can
effectively fight the fed i totally
agree with you i mean honestly there's a
big movement in florida to tell the
senses not to run because you're such a
good governor really yeah people are
like we want him to stay here we don't
want him going federal like right we
want him to stay over here and continue
to do what he's doing like florida's
interesting because it was really purple
and now it's turned pretty solidly right
it's like ohio well all the all the
latinos who came who have family that
were under communist rule they
understand it better than anybody oh
yeah and they're not going to deal with
it miami's got a republican mayor that's
what i'm saying i mean no
no it's like
all the counties in south texas that
were blue for so long are no longer i
mean who hates illegal immigration the
most legal immigrants
hate illegal immigration the most
because those people are diluting their
life
they're taking their
jobs they're diluting their pay and they
didn't do it the right way and they had
to stand in line to do it the right way
and they resent it more than anybody
and so a lot of these houses
people don't live in those those are
those are like
songwriting publishing houses all the
rooms you know like would be in any
house but they're all writers around us
oh that's cool so you'll go in there and
you'll sit down with somebody to write a
song and you can hear somebody through
the wall writing another song and
somebody downstairs that is awesome that
is awesome yeah they estimate somewhere
around a hundred thousand songs a week
get written in nashville whoa hundred
thousand songs a week that's a lot of
songs yeah how many of them are good
it's it's all about the batting average
right exactly
so this has always been interesting to
me what we're pulling up on now i call
this hillbilly porn
this is the headwaters of music row this
is the top of music world right here bam
we're pushing upon it and this is what
they put why is it not a statue of
johnny cash
why is it not patsy cline what is it why
don't we have a mount rushmore of
country
legends
no let's put a bunch of people with
tambourines uh
with their junk hanging out
hillbilly porn
every time i drive by tell my kids close
your eyes boys we're going by the statue
we all hate it
and again that's where that's where you
get a liberal mayor that says i think
they did it on purpose
how many kids do you have two sons
they're 10 and 11.
a lot of fun that is it yeah that's a
that's a lot of testosterone in the
house right there yep that is where
i wrote my very first publishing deal
was right there at that building that's
awesome and uh so that's one of those
writer rooms i was telling you about
that building right there i've probably
written probably 500 songs oh my god in
that little tiny building wow so how
does it how does your process work in
terms of you know you write a song and
then what do you winnow down to actually
recording i so i have written songs
with all different
motivations so
i've written songs because it's
something i want to say and i don't care
if it's a hit but that's how i write
that song because it's a powerful thing
to say the truth in a song that's
powerful then i've written songs
specifically for certain artists so
they'll say okay um
jason aldean is cutting a new record
and he needs up tempo
song about this subject that kind of
sounds like this other hit he had and so
basically it's a sniper shot at that
point so you're going to sit down with a
blank piece of paper with those
instructions and you're going to try to
write that that's almost like trying to
land yeah and try to land the cut i've
written all different kinds of reasons
like one day i get a phone call and it's
taylor swift
i go hey taylor what's up she goes hey
uh i mean i'm in your neighborhood you
want to write a song i went sure let's
write a song it's just out of nowhere i
said i don't have anything going on come
on by the house she goes by the house
and we write a song and it went on her
fearless album which sold like 30
million copies like that songwriting is
interesting i tell people all the time
the most powerful
thing in the world is a blank sheet of
paper and a pencil the constitution of
the united states started out as blank
paper
the bible
the torah anything all of our great
documents started up black paper and
somebody with the pencil and their
thoughts right and that's something
nobody can ever take away from you isn't
that the ultimate freedom
is to have a blank sheet of paper i'm
with you
i almost write netted at the same time
so i write really really fast so i
started talking because you talk so slow
i mean between you and candace it's like
sitting in front of a verbal machine gun
yeah
i mean you guys go at it yeah yeah
definitely blow your hair back so when i
sit down to write i can i can pump
really quickly 750 word comments well
what's the process to get to a point
where you do something like that so i
talk like i write i talk in paragraphs
and so
i write in paragraphs i've done it so
much over the years i've been like you
you know you do it for long enough and
it just comes naturally you don't even
have to think about it
but we write totally opposite so you're
writing long form
i'm writing short form
are you shocked
at where you are
in your life every so often you look
around you go like you go wow yeah i
mean so jeremy and i started this
company in his pool house yeah and i was
the lawyer for a company called talk
radio network which is the syndicator
for michael savage and laura ingram yeah
and my boss was like you guys really
should meet because he was very into
hollywood kind of stuff and so we met we
started talking and
that was in 2009 maybe
and so long ago yes we worked we worked
a couple of jobs together we started a
company called truth revolt i don't know
jeremy ever told you the story about uh
how we got this company started but this
is kind of funny so there are a few key
steps to how we developed one was i
always thought i was going to be the
business guy i mean i was harvard law
school i was a business guy i helped run
the business for talk radio network and
all of this and so in german i met we
thought he's going to be doing hollywood
stuff and i'll be the business guy right
then my book came out uh bullies in
2012. and that's when i was on uh piers
morgan right that was very early 2013.
and so i did that interview with morgan
and blew him off the air and jeremy
turned me said we got this all wrong
you're the talent and i'm the business
wow and so we went in-house at a place
called david horowitz freedom center we
built this company that was kind of
reverse media matters going after
left-wing media companies and we had a
mutually assured destruction strategy
which was if you guys are going to try
and get us boycotted then we're going to
try and get you boycott and we'll knock
you off the air at a certain point
jeremy realized that
what the wright really didn't understand
at all was marketing jeremy's like okay
here's the deal we're going to spend an
awful lot of money on marketing but it's
going to build a machine that's going to
produce money so we go and we're
explaining this to a board of 501c3
conservatives which means everyone is
between 75 and death right no one has
seen a computer they're all writing with
ballpoint well that's why we're getting
our ass kicked if i can just yeah that's
right is that we fight with 501 c3s and
they fight with corporations this is
exactly right so dailywire is way more
successful as an llc right so we so we
walked into the so we go to this meeting
we're trying to explain basically give
us a million dollars and we'll use it on
marketing and we'll build a machine they
don't understand it at all like they
just don't get it and so they turn to me
i'm the fast talking guy he's the slow
draw in texan i had nicknamed him years
ago the stupid whisperer because we
would have conversations with people and
i would say something he's the guy
exactly and it would go right over their
head and then jeremy would say it much
like the same thing much slower right
the soft texas accent and they go oh and
they go that way that's genius so his
pitch so that was more effective
so sometimes so finally they turned to
me and they said explain it and they
said can you simplify this i said yes so
i took out a napkin and a pen and i
wrote here's our business plan dollar
sign arrow facebook arrow website arrow
back to dollar sign this is our entire
business plan we're gonna take money we
invest in facebook it's gonna drive
traffic to our website we're gonna make
money that's the entire business plan
they fire jeremy the next day
yeah they fired jeremy whoa and then i
quit in solidarity and then we took that
exact business plan we went to our
investors you know they're billionaires
and they get all sorts of pitches and so
we're sitting there like we get pitched
on a media company every single day you
know what what makes you guys different
i mean the guy who's kind of asking was
not being particularly nice about it
he's like yeah you know
we get guys in here pitching media
companies every single day why should we
invest in you
and
i looked and i looked in the eye and
said because i'm better at this than any
of those people are there you go
and
they all pause for a second and then
they all started laughing and then we
got the investment so it's either going
to work or wasn't going to work well
isn't that the point though i mean
anybody if you don't believe yourself
that you have something good luck
convincing anybody else you have to
believe it first
i love what you guys are doing when you
see gina carano for instance you see
somebody get brutalized just to say
something that they don't agree with and
then you guys snap them up and continue
their career yeah it's great and then
market them to the people that you know
love them i mean what concept right yeah
can't that play across all counts is
that everything that's the future
everything it's everything of the high
profile cancellations that we've seen
over the past year i've probably reached
out personally to 80 of them no kid what
do they say like are they are they
nervous about so gina was like okay
let's do this thing yeah she understood
innately that they weren't gonna let her
back in and that she had a choice you
could either wheedle and whine her way
into bit parts and maybe five years down
the road they'd start letter acting
again and beg and scrape it right
you know it was t2 right it's terminated
too it's like come with us if you want
to live and so gina got that and she
went for it good for her more that's
going to happen i think sure i think
people have to understand that there's
no way back
there is no forgiveness like people are
still under the misimpression that if
they apologize enough that people will
let them back in this is game of thrones
you show your neck and they will chop
off your head this is not about
guess what else you will lose
all self-respect all integrity here we
are in nashville right country music
home country music do you know who the
audience is for the most part they're a
bunch of blue-collar gun-toting babble
banging
family people yep that's that's who they
are but guess what the industry is yep
[Music]
starting to figure it out a little bit
but nobody's connected those dots if
they realized
whose money
was involved in the radio station that
they listened to in their hometown and
who those people are they would never
listen to it again yeah and by the way
all these artists
that want to say what they want to say
and if they say it on a stage 20 000
people go hell yeah
say that again
or not are not saying it because their
label their publicist their manager the
booking agency whatever is gonna wipe
them out exactly they have killed
their freedom of speech now then it come
down though to the to the person like
hey they didn't kill your freedom of
speech you're allowing them to kill your
speech you could say it nobody's putting
a sock in your mouth they cannot cancel
you unless you allow them to cancel you
exactly right if you have an audience
and you're good at what you do they
cannot cancel you only you can get
that's how i come at it yep
i mean i'm out there sorry just hit your
camera do i need to adjust this camera
by the way you guys hear me whoever can
hear me in the car i don't know i just
hit that i hope that's still seeing you
hey
i hit the camera is it okay good to see
y'all
okay hey thank you
i'm just sitting there thinking about
all this and i went you know what i am
not saying what i want to say or being
who i want to be
because
if i do it the music industry there will
not be another hit song at country radio
there will not be another award there
will not be any of it but one day i just
said you know what i'm sick of this and
so i just started swinging coming at
them they no longer come back at me
anymore because they realize i'm not
going to stop doing it and eventually
they just give up yeah exactly as long
as you don't stop it's bla it's blood in
the water if you if you give them blood
in the water they will just crowd swarm
you but if you don't if you're just like
okay all right you know you said what
you're gonna say and that's pretty much
all you can do today and i'm still here
exactly then they really have no place
to go i feel like we're just providing a
home for people who wanna who want to
speak out and want to want a safe place
to go
and an alternative
so when when are we going to get you
how's it going
i know right hey thanks for coming like
what's up country star genre what's the
new duo it's it's ben and rich
y'all are awesome it was so cool it was
great thank you so much appreciate it
you too yeah exactly nashville
jeremy told me that you guys were
talking about doing doing a label and
i'm i'm so into it i'm so into it you
would take ground away from them yeah
because we don't need them anymore not
if you've got a platform like that
exactly exactly the crossover between
our audience and your audience is
probably not everything you look up and
daily wire records as the number one
spot in country music
that's a party exactly
exactly
that day that day will happen it won't
be smoky mike in the god king i can
guarantee you that that is the thing
that's not going to happen so yeah we'd
have to work on that one so you're a
violin guy yeah plates in between so i
was heavily trained between the time i
was five and one of these days dude we
have got to get you down here at my bar
we got to play stuff oh i'll totally do
that if anybody throws me a fiddle out
though
yeah that'd be super fun
my dad's a fantastic jazz pianist i grew
up with him and so he and i you know
like at my bar mitzvah we played brahms
together he comes over he comes over to
the house before sabbath and we'll like
break out beethoven and stuff and really
together yeah
so we're on broadway right now live
bands in every single door there's more
beer sold per square foot on this street
than anywhere on the planet
that's a fact that's awesome
more than the french quarter more than
las vegas more than any anywhere right
here
so this is my bar
oh wow these buildings were all built in
1850s oh my gosh so my building hand cut
brick you know they made the old school
brick 1851. oh my god and my building
was actually used as a hospital during
the civil war right in front of us is
the cumberland river when the civil war
broke out the confederates were right
here the north came right down the
cumberland river with their boats and
started cannonball in downtown nashville
so it's the history's deep
[Music]
so what are your boys into they're all
sports fanatics yeah baseball is big
baseball and basketball so i got my my
son cash out there
hey how's it going dude hey thank you he
was playing a basketball game and they
were getting humiliated by this other
team i mean it was like 62 to 10. it's
awful and cash grabs his knee and he
goes and sits down they put ice on his
knee and
and i said he better be heard he's
better
well when the game he never went back in
the game when the game's over he jumps
up from the bench throws the ice on the
floor and walks out the door like
nothing ever happened
he's in my truck we're driving home i
said you know what you are
he goes
what i said you're a loser
and he goes i know cause we lost the
game i said no you're not a loser
because you lost the game you're a loser
because you quit the game so i walked
him in and showed him his his great
granddaddy's who both fought in world
war ii one had six purple hearts oh my
god he was five two 110
and was a tunnel rat whether he'd send
him in the cave with a flamethrower to
flush the japanese pacific yeah he's
that guy so i made him go look at his
world war ii uniform that night and i
said you think that man's a quitter
his big old tears this culture is
teaching our kids that it's okay to quit
it's okay to give up if it's too hard
you can stop if you don't get what you
want throw a fit and nobody's going to
win
that attitude not in the real world
exactly
hey what's going on
that's got to make you feel good right
drive around nashville exactly and all
the possible music fans like ben shapiro
exactly that's what i'm saying
hey how's it going guys
yeah they love you bro i love you that's
why i had that party for you all yeah
that was like that one if you're going
to come to my town i'm going to make
sure you know we appreciate you i will
admit that i had a good time sticking a
meatloaf on candace so i was absolutely
right and so he walked over to the table
he's the nicest bunch of guys i've ever
met
[Laughter]
so tonight actually on fox business i
have a show called the pursuit
so meatloaf is on tonight so basically
it's about the pursuit of happiness why
interview people about their pursuit of
happiness in their life but he goes
he goes john
when i was in ninth grade man
i wanted to be a professional baseball
player one day i'm out there practicing
and i hear a kid go watch out and he
says i turn around and there's a 16
pound shot put about three feet from my
head like i just look and there it is
and wham hits me in the head and i went
into it basically a coma for three days
at the hospital and when i got out of
the hospital i could sing he goes you
don't believe me feel it and he leans
his head over and he goes there's a flat
spot on my head and sure enough about
that big there's a flat spot on
meatloaf's head but he said he said he
never played baseball again and went
tried out for theater in his high school
wow and that's where it started that's
wild is that crazy that that's a wild
story and he goes yeah one time i was in
amsterdam back then he's selling a
hundred thousand tickets yeah he's the
biggest he's queen he's the biggest
thing there is yeah i was in amsterdam
i don't remember what all drugs i've
done but i've done a bunch he said i'm
sitting backstage i'm getting ready to
go out and he goes you know who walked
up to me i started talking to me i said
who he said
a version of abraham lincoln
i said
a version
of abraham lincoln he goes yeah and he's
dead serious he goes you know what he
said to me
no me what did he say he goes
he said he looked me right in the eye
and he said go out the back door this
time
crazy so yes he's a crazy bastard but
what a talent
so you're in the belly of the beast
right here buddy
so blake shelton's joint is right there
that's kid rox bar right there welcome
to the redneck river here yeah buddy
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a sweet place
yeah
not a main block called the heroes car
if you're active duty or a vet or a cop
first drinks on the house that's awesome
so we have done thousands of thousands
of drinks on the house so people search
this far out from all over america
especially cops because we back the blue
here yeah we've got to find more walls
to put them up yeah exactly it's like a
thing to do
they sing the star-spangled banner in
here every single night at midnight
amazing everybody's salute
yeah exactly exactly
as a kid that grew up in a trailer park
in texas that sings country music i
never thought demeanors i would have my
own place on broadway and exactly that's
a great story yeah that's an
unbelievable story so i'm i'm kind of
shocked every time i walk in here i
can't believe this in my joint when
people crap on this country they do not
know what they're talking about it can
absolutely be done you guys want to go
up top
[Music]
what an awesome place right so cool
this is the wild west yeah
but what is more country
than the american flag made out of that
here that is that not the greatest the
daily wire needs a beer can american
flag somewhere i feel like i feel like
that would go over in our offices man
the bar business is not an easy business
right how did you decide that you were
just going to go ahead and do that how
did you decide that you're going to tell
the whole world to kiss your ass and
you're going to start daily wire yeah is
that true it's okay it's something i
want to do last time i checked i have
the freedom to exhaust my potential so
i'm going to take risks i'm going to
step out and do things that i think may
or may not work but we're going to find
out redneck riviera whiskey is now in 12
000 stores amazing so think about this
you have the word redneck in today's
culture sitting in 12 000 stores around
america and nobody's kicked it out they
go i don't like the word i go do you
know where the word comes from it's from
people that have been over working all
day outside they get a sunburn on their
neck
it's like a it's like a
term of endearment it's also it's also
pride it's like i'm a hard working guy
i'm hard working girl i got a redneck i
built this building i built the brand
everything
around the love of america the right to
pursue happiness
work ethic it's awesome
very simple so when you're running for
mayor over here
i could ask that a lot i'm sure you
didn't tell people uh i said you know
anybody that's a career politician has a
mental disorder that is true because
they're not good people and if you enjoy
it that much something is wrong with you
totally agree so this is literally
people ask me like what's your first
requirement a politician and i said they
don't want to run for office so that was
a quote from john adams back in the day
he said only people that detest politics
should run for office exactly will i
ever run for something i don't know
maybe when the mustache turns white and
my boys are this time hey listen i mean
the average age of our politicians is
80. so you got a long time to figure it
out right
hope you had a good time that was an
awesome day it was fun showing you
around hey thank you next time we're
bringing that photo perfect do a little
jam bring your dad we'll rock and roll
we love you in this town we love what
you guys stand for and we're glad you're
in nashville glad you got the hell out
of california well thank you so much for
having us
[Music]
you